ce soir les enfants c'est un bon soir
très rapides que nous venons vous dire
ce soir car nous partons en espagne
bravo à l'espagne walken dourges
mais nous faisons juste un aller retour
rien de plus bada bar miteux et nounours
comme vous le voyez veut apprendre à
parler l'espagnol part oum brute au port
dont oui pas trop nous allons descend
vite dire bonne nuit à nos deux petits
amis allons-y femme au look modem bon le
seul jeu bob brennan noche petite hausse
mulcair qui dans qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça c'est tôt l'espagnol ça signifie
bonne nuit les petits parce que
j'accompagne mon patron en espagne nous
partons en voyage ce soir c'est gai au
voyage pour un voyage d'affaires
bonne pioche ou de vienne mais bien et
nous qu'est ce qu'on va faire pendant ce
temps vous allez être très sage
ça change pas en quoi on fait juste un
aller retour et après demain nous serons
la moquette
tu as peut-être toujours la même chose
tu connais pas d'autre mot espagne où
mon pauvre non non ce ils vont rire de
toit les espagnols seront bien étonné
j'en connais des mots et d'être
difficile je leur dirai à lille bas
espagne à wingles magna qu'est ce que
c'est ça signifie vive l'espagne et ça
leur fera très plaisir et après all he
added on s'est amusé en espagne à
écouter you thank go home ben oui bien
très bien
you tengo hambre j'ai faim et comme il
ya beaucoup de soleil en espagne il ya
beaucoup de fruits et d'être à de bonnes
choses mimi alors je demande poliment
mais na na na one pass platanes as des
pommes des oranges des bananes et enfin
toro de al bayane
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi du nougat au miel tel quel
merveilleux
arriba espagnols arrivent en espagne à
quand tu reviens tu nous demanderait la
fusion pourtant bonne indigestion gros
gourmand tapantes
moi non mais l'on oublie si vous êtes
sages je vous rapporterait une surprise
vamos négoce heureusement que j'ai
changé bien sous aile quand j'ai
beaucoup pensé à ce qu'on me sign on
s'est promis bleus mais tu n'auras
portrait une belle surprise elle était
majeure a pas trop de torts aux manuels
télé jean marc drogue
ces pros ni la jettent à la lumière
world of books négoce buenas noches
mignot ce bonnet n'annonce revient vite
connu nicolas pona mouchage apprenent
elle connue des enfants et soyez
tranquilles je surveillerai nounours il
ne mangera pas trop bas mot ce pas trop
vamos nounours en route walken leur fait
debout rêve
buenas noches
[Musique]
auj
où
avant
en
[Applaudissements]